est ce que vous mangez bien vous c'est
pas facile comme question pour répondre
il faut déjà savoir ce que ça veut dire
vraiment bien manger et puis une fois
qu'on dit a répondu il en reste encore
une autre ok mais comment on fait pour y
arriver parce que c'est pas si simple et
bah c'est pile ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui c'est plein de bien faire
bien manger c'est quoi un célèbre
nutritionniste a répondu à cette
question par il faut manger un peu de
tout mon grand père disait ça aussi
d'ailleurs ils étaient ni célèbre très
sioniste donc c'est précieux en
l'occurrence manger un peu ça veut dire
manger moins parce que globalement ce
n'est pas tout le monde mais dans nos
sociétés et manger de tout c'est pour
dire qu'il faut avoir une alimentation
diversifiée
imparable même s'ils m'ont plongé de
tous pas sûr
pas sûr du tout surtout qu'on mange des
trucs dont on n'a pas besoin et qu'ils
nous foutent pas nul et puis il ya des
trucs qui se retrouvent dans ce qu'on
mange etc ont rien à [ __ ] là est
encore là on parle que de ce car
l'impact direct sur notre santé bien
manger c'est manger ce dont on a besoin
pour vivre en évitant ce qui est mauvais
pour notre santé mais aussi pour celle
de la planète c'est aussi y manger sans
se ruiner et sans ruiner les gens qui
produisent ce qu'on mange et puis c'est
manger des trucs qui nous font plaisir
quand même parce que oui le plaisir est
important bon alors comment est ce qu'on
fait tout ça à la fois c'est très
complexe de répondre à cette question
donc on va faire un truc on va répondre
à cette question en répondant à 16
questions
je vous avais prévenus c'est complexe
une alimentation équilibrée c'est quoi
la première chose qui vient à l'esprit
quand on parle de bien manger c'est ça
c'est un équilibre nutritionnel
alors déjà c'est quelque chose qui est
super variable suivant ou en vie et
comment oui globalement dans nos modes
de vie occidentaux ça revient à savoir
ce qu'on doit longer pour que notre
corps fonctionne correctement mais aussi
ce qu'on doit manger moins pour éviter
se rendent malade parce que le problème
c'est surtout ça pour schématiser l'idée
c'est d'aller piocher dans tous les
groupes d'aliments mais pas dans les
mêmes quantités et pas la même fréquence
pour se repérer ya plein de
recommandations sous forme de tableaux
de pyramide à sienne de diagrammes etc
je vous mets tout ça dans la description
de la vidéo mais en gros les trucs à
retenir c'est ça dans une pyramide
alimentaire c'est-à-dire le reflet
en quantité et en fréquence l'anase lots
ensuite c'est les prix et les légumes
les féculents les légumes secs et des
céréales c'est la base et pourtant on ne
nous sommes pas assez de ces trois lieux
ensuite il ya trois autres groupes
d'aliments qu'on a tendance à trop
consommer les produits d'origine animale
comme les produits laitiers les oeufs le
poisson la viande sur lesquelles on va
revenir un peu plus tard mais matière
grasse dont on a besoin mais en faibles
quantités
et puis en août dernier les produits
dont on n'a pas besoin et qu'il faut
consommer de manière exceptionnelle
comme l'alcool les produits sucrés et ça
vaut aussi pour les boissons les
produits transformés mais on va reparler
de tout ça aussi après combien de repas
ou doit faire par jour contrairement à
ce qu'on pense c'est pas si facile que
ça de répondre à cette question le
schéma classique en france en tout cas
c'est trois par jour avec éventuellement
une collation déjà on peut se dire que
si vous faites ça vous n'êtes pas là
mais il ya aussi d'autres études qui
recommande d'autres schémas comme deux
repas par jour avec une grande pause
entre les 2 par exemple la vérité c'est
qu'il ya pas de vérité parce que ça
dépend des paramètres qu'on prend en
compte pour arriver à ces conclusions et
que vous le savez on est des petites
bêtes complexe mais le truc à retenir le
plus important c'est la régularité il
faut répartir les apports de façon
cohérente sur la journée mais surtout il
faut le faire au même rythme d'abord
parce que ça permet à notre organisme de
mieux assimiler ce qu'on mange ensuite
parce que ça lui évite de stocker si on
saute à repas par exemple et aussi parce
que ça limite les risques de grignotage
qui ont tendance à nous faire manger
plus que nécessaire ou les aliments dont
on n'a pas vraiment besoin ou qu'on
mange déjà entre grands est-ce qu'il
faut vraiment manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour bon on va pas se mentir
c'est le genre de message qui décourage
mais si on gratte un petit peu pour voir
ce que ça cache sa part est tout de
suite moins impossible en fait ça se
base sur des rapports qui recommande de
manger 400 grammes de fruits et légumes
par jour et comme une portion de fruits
ou de légumes c'est 80 g bahotencs safex
en fonction d'enjeux l'avantagent si
vous manger 5 portions de fruits et
légumes différents c'est que 1 vous
diversifiez vos apports en nutriments et
2 vous diminuer les risques d'être
exposés aux pesticides par exemple mais
si vous en manger 400 grammes par jour
sans que ce soit forcément des fruits et
des légumes différents à chaque fois
c'est déjà pas mal et si vous choisissez
des fruits et des légumes de saison
c'est encore mieux parce que hors saison
ils sont cultivés avec des moyens plus
polluants et en utilisant plus de
pesticides ou alors ils viennent de
l'autre bout du monde avec tout ce que
ça implique sans même parler du
suremballage est-ce que l'on gère
équilibré ça suffit pour être en bonne
santé un banon j'en ai déjà parlé manger
équilibré ça permet juste d'avoir les
apports nutritionnels et énergétiques
dont notre corps a besoin en évitant les
excès qui peuvent le rendre malade et ça
doit aller avec une activité physique
adaptée par exemple si on parle juste de
bouffe évidemment il ya aussi la qualité
de ce qu'on a je tire longe bien nos
portions de fruits et de légumes mais
qui sont blindés de pesticides on l'a
bien nos apports nutritionnels mais en
terme de santé c'est un oeuf et puis il
ya les additifs vous avez des trucs
qu'on met dans certains aliments pour
les faire gonfler échanger leurs
textures leur aspect leur couleur ou
juste leur donner plus de goût
évidemment s'ils sont utilisés c'est
qu'ils sont autorisés jusqu'au moment où
on se rend compte que finalement tout
son passé inoffensif et puis surtout il
ya ce qu'on appelle l'effet cocktail
jeter un petit coup d'oeil à l'étiquette
de ce que vous achetez vous verrez
parfois la liste elle est sacrée monnier
et dites vous bien que là on parle de
produits qui sont complètement inutiles
et qu'on ne sait pas vraiment quel effet
le mélange peut avoir sur notre santé
surtout si on allonge toi pour être
clair si vous devez retenir le nom d'une
catégorie à éviter à tout prix le voilà
les animaux ultra troubles c'est quoi un
aliment ultra transformer les aliments
ultra transformer c'est
malin à tout point de vue nutritionnel
et pour l'environnement mais c'est quoi
en fait un aliment ultra transformer
c'est un truc qu'on achète tout près et
dont les ingrédients ont subi plusieurs
étapes de transformation complexe pour
ressembler au produit final des étapes
de transformation industrielle mais
aussi comme on l'a déjà dit des additifs
pas ouf et en plus de ça une bonne
grosse dose de matières grasses et ou de
sel et ou de sucres ajoutés donc en gros
ils contiennent très peu de ce dont on a
besoin beaucoup de ce qu'on devra éviter
et en plus tout un tas de trucs qui
servent à rien et dont on sait patron
les effets qui peuvent avoir à long
terme donc oui là on parle des cordons
bleus des nuggets etc mais pas seulement
si vous faites vos courses dans un
supermarché par exemple sachez que dans
les rayons cet aliment sur dix sont une
tradition y compris les jus de fruits
les yaourts les céréales pour le petit
déjeuner et l'immense majorité des
produits diététiques est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter la viande à on rentre dans les
questions qui fâchent alors soyons clair
ici on va pas parler de souffrance
animale c'est une question importante
qu'il faut se poser mais c'est pas
vraiment le sujet là on va juste se
placer d'un point de vue purement son t2
chiffre d'abord les recommandations en
viande sans compter la volaille qu'un
petit peu à part c'est pas plus de 500
grammes par semaine ça fait à peu près
trois quatre steaks par semaine et des
experts ont estimé dans un rapport que
je cite chaque portion de 50 g de
viandes transformées consommer
quotidiennement accroît le risque de
cancer colorectal 2 18% voilà donc dit
autrement on mange trop de viande etc
est mauvais pour notre santé mais c'est
pas fini d'un point de vue
environnemental
l'une des activités humaines qui à
l'impact le plus négatif c'est celle qui
est liée à notre alimentation est en
première place la production de viande
entre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la déforestation pour planter de
quoi nourrir les bêtes et l'utilisation
massive des ressources notamment en eau
les élevages ça fait pas du bien à la
planète et vous serez peut-être surpris
de savoir que dans un autre registre la
déforestation et les formes d'élevage
intensif avec d'immenses populations
d'animaux de la même espèce regroupés au
même endroit ça favorise qu'on appelle
les zoonoses c'est à dire la
transmission de virus de l'animal vers
l'homme
et c'est ce qui crée des épidémies voir
des pandémies mondiales
je sais pas si vous voyez où je veux en
venir donc je suis pas là pour vous dire
si vous devez arrêter la viande ou pas
mais clairement les recommandations
c'est d'en manger moins et de meilleure
qualité et soyez tranquille vous n'allez
pas être car on sait ce qu'il ya dans
l'avion vous trouvez aussi ailleurs
juste si vous décider d'arrêter
complètement la viande faudra faire
attention à ce que vous mangez pour
compenser surtout avec la vitamine b12
si vous choisissez une alimentation
végétalienne est ce qu'il faut manger
bio alors soyons clairs niveau santé
l'intérêt principal de manger bio c'est
d'éviter l'exposition aux pesticides au
niveau nutritionnel pur la différence
elle est pas évidente mais c'est déjà
pas mal parce que le lien entre cancer
et pesticides nuit là bien l'été et
table donc dans l'absolu oui manger bio
ça limite ce genre de risque et puis
même si ça a parfois été remis en cause
on a quand même de plus en plus
d'éléments qui nous démontre que
l'agriculture bio elle est moins
mauvaise pour l'environnement pascal
épuisement à leurs ressources et qu'elle
respecte la biodiversité et tout ça ça a
un impact indirect sur notre santé mais
attention il faut savoir de quelle bio
on parle si c'est du bio qui vient de
l'autre
déjà est ce qu'on sait vraiment comment
ça a été produit et puis surtout le
bilan carbone de votre bouche ni les pas
génial donc faut se renseigner sans
oublier un autre gros problème avec le
bio c'est cher c'est cher parce que
c'est un peu plus cher à produire mais
c'est aussi plus cher parce que la
grande distribution se fait des belles
sur marche dessus surtout sur les fruits
et légumes bon ça on peut espérer que ça
finisse par changer mais pour l'instant
c'est cher est ce qu'on peut faire
confiance aux labels ah ouais mais la
belle le problème avec les labels déjà
section l'appelant et qu'on connaît pas
toujours tous les critères qu'il faut
remplir pour les avoir c'est pas facile
de s'y retrouver mais si on reprend
l'exemple du bio on peut raisonnablement
se dire que si on achète un produit avec
un label bio on a clairement moins de
risque d'être exposés aux pesticides est
un tout un tas d'autres saloperies que
si on prend un produit qui ne garantit
donc ce n'est pas une assurance tous
risques mais disons confection et le
mythe risque au web vous savez le
nutrisse corse et ce truc qui classe les
aliments selon qui son hockey au niveau
nutritionnel
l'avantagent ce qui permet d'avoir des
infos en un coup d'oeil et dans certains
pays ça a permis de diminuer la
consommation de produits trop gras trop
sucré trop salé vous connaissez
aussi
mais attention il faut savoir s'en
servir correctement le nitrile score et
donne une indication individuel sur
chaque produit mais est-ce que l'aliment
en question il est indispensable ça ça
le dis pas par exemple on peut avoir des
chips notés a ou b mais ça reste des
aliments ultra transformer donc à éviter
ou à limiter aux halles inverse on peut
avoir des huiles de cuisson noté eux ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas les
utiliser ça veut juste dire qu'il faut y
aller mollo ça reste un score par
catégories alimentaires mais ça indique
pas dans quelle quantité on peut le
consommer donc le nutrisse corps ça peut
aider à choisir entre plusieurs produits
du même groupe mais à ça veut pas dire
open bar il faut replacer cela dans le
contexte d'un régime alimentaire
équilibré comme
et les appuis qu'ils se calment les
codes barres c'est à peu près la même
réponse que pour le nôtre y score avec
en plus une petite question sur
l'origine des données utilisées pour
classer les animaux dans l'absolu on
peut admettre que c'est plutôt fiable
juste ça reste une aide pour choisir
entre plusieurs produits mais la base
c'est d'avoir conscience de ce que c'est
vraiment que bien manger bien attention
il faut pas que manger ça devienne une
psychose ok mais comment je fais mes
courses et déjà n'allez pas faire vos
courses le ventre vide ça vous évitera
d'acheter n'importe quoi juste parce que
vous avez la dalle ensuite la première
étape on en a déjà parlé c'est d'avoir
les notions de base sur l'équilibré
alimentaire c'est à dire sur la quantité
et la fréquence à laquelle il faut qu'on
longe chaque groupe d'aliments ensuite
le meilleur conseil c'est de prévoir ses
menus et de faire sa liste de courses en
conséquence ça permet de se concentrer
sur la qualité des produits ça permet
aussi de limiter les achats impulsifs et
sa limite aussi les risques de gâchis si
vous voulez aller plus loin vous pouvez
aussi tenter le bats cooking en gros ça
revient à prévoir tous ces menus de la
semaine à l'avancé et à tout cuisiné de
ces économique vous n'êtes plus
regardants sur la qualité et sur les
quantités et puis ça vous libère du
temps et de la charge mentale la semaine
il ya même des ateliers de badges
cooking en commun du combat on peut
échanger ses recettes et c'est plus
sympa mais pour en revenir aux courses
un conseil important pour éviter les
fameuses aliments ultra transformé il
faut regarder la liste des ingrédients
s'il y en a peut excéder truc qu'on peut
trouver dans le placard c'est ok mais
quand il commence à y regarder non seul
ou avec plein de chiffres et plein de
lettres c et des additifs donc
s'épanouir et plus la liste est longue -
c'est bon au début c'est un peu l'eau de
faire le tri mais avec l'habitude s'agir
fluide ok là on parle des supermarchés
mais est ce qu'il faut manger local
c'est vrai qu'on entend ça souvent c'est
plutôt justes mais il faut quand même se
poser quelques questions déjà le local
ça concerne essentiellement les produits
frais et au niveau nutritionnel le
transport les dégrade assez peu donc
c'est pas à ce niveau là que le problème
se situe et puis c'est bien mais si vous
faites 20 kilomètres en voiture pour
aller acheter une caisse de tomates
c'est contreproductif pour environ alors
que si vous l'achetez chez le primeur de
votre quartier ok il ya un intermédiaire
en plus mais lui il est allé chercher
les produits du coin en grande quantité
donc la note carbone elles baissent et
puis ça veut dire quoi locale parce que
suivant la région vous habitez ça va
être difficile d'avoir une alimentation
équilibrée si vous consommez que ce qui
est produit sur place donc l'idée c'est
surtout de savoir comment les aliments
ont été produits et de préférer ceux qui
n'ont pas fait le tour du monde avant de
finir dans votre salade et de façon plus
pragmatique si vous achetez des trucs
produits en europe c'est déjà pas mal et
pour le sucre on fait quoi au niveau
nutritionnel soyons clairs on n'a pas
besoin des trucs sucrées comme ce qu'on
est dans tes ou dans le café comme les
desserts et tout ce qu'on appelle les
sucres libres ils ont même des effets
négatifs sur la santé et on recommande
50 grammes max voire idéalement 25 g max
de sucres libres par jour sachant qu'une
canette de coca c'est 35 grammes et qui
a déjà dû sucres cachés un peu partout
notamment dans les aliments ultra
transformer comme le sel pareil en fait
on a besoin de glucides pain de sucre au
sens où l'entend en général et avec les
glucides qui a dans une alimentation
équilibrée notre organisme est largement
de quoi faire donc soyons clairs - en
ange de trucs sucre et mios et après
attention on a le droit de se faire
plaisir parce que ça aussi c'est bon
pour la santé mais ça doit rester un
luthier plaisir exceptionnel ça doit pas
faire partie de notre alimentation
quotidienne parce qu'en vrai ça nous
sert à rien et ça nous fait même du mal
parce que ça provoque certaines maladies
comme le diabète des problèmes
cardiovasculaires ou certains concerts
d'autant plus que le sucre il a un gros
potentiel addictif donc moins on en
mange moins on risque d'avoir envie d'en
manger sans pouvoir s'empêcher et pour
finir un petit mot sur les édulcorants
leurs effets sur la santé ils sont
encore mal connus et puis surtout ils
entretiennent ce goût pour le sucré donc
finalement y pousse à la consommation et
les produits laitiers alors oui vous
savez nos amis pour la vie c'est une
question qui fait débat même dans la
communauté scientifique mais on va
essayer de regarder les choses de
manière factuelle d'un point de vue
nutritionnel on nous a longtemps raconté
qu'il fallait absolument en consommer
tous les jours pour couvrir nos besoins
en calcium notamment mais en réalité du
calcium y en a plein dans d'autres
aliments et parfois même plus que dans
les produits laitiers donc clairement à
ce niveau là ils sont pas indispensables
tous les nutriments qui contiennent on
peut les trouver ailleurs à condition
d'avoir une alimentation variée
d'ailleurs il ya certains pays qui les
ont retirées des recommandations y en a
d'autres qui conseille plutôt les laits
végétaux et en france on a juste
diminuer les quantités reconnu
concernant leurs effets positifs ou
négatifs sur la santé là aussi il ya
débat disons qu'il ya du pour et du
contre et que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord par contre on a déjà parlé de
l'élevage industriel et ça c'est un
concerne aussi les produits laitiers
moralité on peut se dire que non on n'en
n'a pas absolument besoin est que comme
pour tous les autres produits d'origine
animale on a intérêt à se calmer sur les
produits laitiers et comment on fait
pour bien manger sans se ruiner ouais
faut manger bio faut longer de la
qualité tout ça c'est cher donc quand
vous entendez ça ne coûte pas plus cher
de bien margés je comprends que vous
ayez du mal à y croire alors il ya
plusieurs projets qui donnent des
solutions on va pas tout détailler mais
je vous remets les liens dans la
description si vous voulez aller voir
mais on devrait si vous vous passez tous
combien de se dire bien mangé ça veut
dire manger des produits de bonne
qualité ok mais ça veut dire aussi
manger bon si on prend l'exemple de la
viande par exemple l'idée c'est
d'acheter de la viande de meilleure
qualité donc plus chers mais ils
essaient aussi d'en manger moins et
moins souvent donc et puis les autres
conseils genre préparer ses menus à
l'avance voir cuisiner en commun ça fait
aussi baisser la note donc ça
s'équilibre et comment on fait pour
manger sans gêner les autres ouais bien
manger c'est pas seulement manger des
trucs qui sont des cons soit c'est aussi
manger des trucs qui font pas de mal aux
autres est ce que les petits producteurs
et toute la main d'oeuvre qui
travaillent sont payés correctement tout
au long de la chaîne avant que ce que
vous avez mangé arrive jusqu'à vous
c'est pas toujours facile de s'y
retrouver là aussi il ya des labels
commerce équitable qui sont plus ou
moins claires et plus ou moins fiables
mais gardez un truc à l'esprit si vous
achetez un truc vraiment pas cher c'est
qu'il ya quelqu'un quelque part qui paye
la note un producteur une productrice
une ouvrière 1 éveillé une livreuse un
livreur
longer éthique et équitable ça a un prix
et c'est comme pour tout on donne ce
qu'on peut et puis surtout sur ce point
comme sur tous les autres en fait c'est
important de faire attention à notre
niveau individuellement mais les grands
changements ils devront en effet à
grande échelle n'empêche qu'en changeant
nos habitudes de consommation on peut
pousser les industriels et les états à
bouger aussi voilà donc bien manger
c'est tout ça c'est un équilibre
nutritionnel à respecter mais pas
seulement parce que les enjeux dépassent
le cadre de notre tube digestif c'est
une réflexion globale à avoir fait des
réflexes à prendre des habitudes à
perdre et c'est alors ça peut paraître
beaucoup comme ça mais déjà ça serait
bien et attention on a le droit d'y
aller au fur et à mesure et puis il faut
rester à l'aise avec ce qu'on ne faut
pas que ça devienne une psychose une
espèce de source d'angoissé en plus les
repas c'est des moments qu'on les
dimensions sociales et qui peuvent être
une source de bien-être psychologique
est évidemment tout ça c'est important
aussi donc l'idée c'est d'avoir les
grandes lignes en tête et de faire le
mieux possible en évitant au moins de
faire toujours les mêmes erreurs de les
faire trop souvent aller avant de se
quitter et je vous donne 14 conseils
pour vraiment bien manger à table buvez
de l'eau le reste du temps aussi de
préférence globalement manger moins mais
de meilleure qualité servez des petites
portions on a souvent tendance à finir
son assiette alors qu'on a pu faire
diminuer le sucre est au maximum genre
un petit plaisir de temps en temps
diminuer le sel aussi pareil pour les
graisses ajouté diminués et varier les
sources au maximum diminuer les produits
d'origine animale et augmenter les
fruits les légumes et les céréales
évitez les produits ultra transformer
choisissez les produits frais et brut du
coup cuisine est plutôt que de manger
des plats tout préparés prévoyez-vous
menu avant d'aller faire vos courses et
il n'y avait pas le ventre vide préparer
vos repas à l'avant ce genre le dimanche
après midi avec des potes si vous le
sentez choisissez des produits bio de
saison qu'ils n'ont pas à traverser la
planète pour arriver jusqu'à nous garder
un oeil sur la provenance et le prix de
ce que vous mangez vous souvenez si ça
coûte fiancée qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
n'est pas payé correctement et puis
faites vous plaisir rongé ça doit pas
devenir une source de stress comme ça
vous avez les grandes lignes après
évidemment chacun fait comme on peut
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]